no matter what I post to Instagram
someone has a major problem with it I'm
always committing some transgression
unbeknownst to me whenever I post
something to Instagram of course I'm on
instagram at david pakman these are two
of the most popular images from my
Instagram over the last week or so and
you would think that these are
relatively harmless images the first one
is I have been trying to improve my
skills at making latte art with when I
make coffee with my espresso machine and
I made a relatively ok looking leaf
based on my incredibly limited skills
and immediately people were saying David
your crema color is uneven see how the
crema is darker at the bottom of the
picture then at the top of the picture
your crema is uneven and also there's
like a stray white line sort of at the
top I'm not a barista you know it's like
I make four coffees a week and I mess
around and try to do something no matter
what I do someone has a criticism also
somebody said that I shouldn't be using
whole milk because skim milk foams
better I want whole milk okay I'm just
having the whole milk see I thought the
backlash would come from the vegan
community which says don't use any
animal products no anytime I post you
know interestingly I don't think there's
a comment about that for this picture
but usually there's like at least one
comment which is like David go vegan I
think that's not the subject of what
we're talking about here so anyway a
coffee picture people didn't like it
then I posted that I was reading I
recently started reading the history of
western philosophy by bertrand russell
and the book so far has been great and
it really gives it's not only a look at
the philosophical ideas of different
philosophers but it's a history of the
context of many of those philosophers
and immediately people start slamming me
pat saying stuff like oh that's a really
biased view on the history of western
philosophy well what what comprehensive
history of such a broad topic isn't
going to have some biases and
immediately I was getting slammed
because this is a very you know it's a
very partial history of the matter
I can't I can't do anything right on my
Instagram and of course you can't become
fully detached from your own diocese but
at the same time you have to have some
trust in the world right yeah you can
take something like the history of
something as fact yeah and it's just a
basis it's an initial basis and then you
take and you read the individual
philosophers that you're interested in
and then you might read a history of
Eastern philosophy and then a critique
of Bertrand Raleigh it's one book at a
time folks right I mean don't don't
don't go after me for everything i post
to my Instagram and it's a philosophy
book it's meant to inspire critical
thinking and I think that's what you're
doing that's exactly right follow me on
instagram more than 10,000 people now do
david pakman on instagram